hi everybody I'm Laura Ingram this is
Ingram angle from Washington tonight
come and take it that's the focus of
tonight's
angle all right good news from the Texas
AG Ken Paxton today the Lone Star State
does not intend to bend to federal
agents trying to enter Shelby Park in
Eagle Pass now the agents use the park
as kind of a staging ground to process
migrants and do other things uh migrants
to Crossing into the United States but
Texas governor Greg Abbott released a
statement remember on Tuesday accusing
Biden of violating his constitutional
duties to execute immigration laws and
then today
this the authors of the Constitution
knew there would be times when the
federal government would not live up to
his duty and so they empowered States in
Article 1 Section 10 the right of
self-defense and what Texas is asserting
is our Article 1 Section 10 right of
self-defense because theid president of
the United States is not fulfilling his
duty to enforce the laws passed by
Congress that deny illegal entry into
the United States well Abbot is 100%
correct from day one of his presidency
Biden and his puppeteers have done
everything possible to signal to the
world that it's open season at the US
border everything we all know the
results a complete catastrophe and a
windfall for transnational gangs and
child sex traffickers I only wish that
Texas had done what it's doing now
sooner now Biden's lawyers are in
federal court remember as this is all
happening suing Texas for taking actions
to secure its border it's just shameful
so if you're living in a state where
your Governor has not issued a statement
supporting Texas and it standoff with
the federal government at the border
then at this point you should consider
moving now the list is growing of
Republicans who are pledging to stand
with Texas about 24 Governors now and
again against the bid administration's
attempts to facilitate illegal border
crossings into the US now all of these
are states led by Governors who care
about preserving our country and
certainly care about preserving our rule
of law so I'm asking tonight where's
Kathy hokel of New York where's Mora
Healey of Massachusetts where's Andy
basher of Kentucky remember he's such a
moderate and where's JB pritsker of
Illinois well expect only crickets from
them which means only one thing they
support Biden and his open borders more
than they care about their own residents
is that a heck with a strain on kids
schools hospitals law enforcement State
budgets I don't worry about that they
care more about giving political cover
to Biden on an issue than like like this
than closing the border to the cartels
and the
traffickers and speaking of shameful are
the US senators so desperate to shovel
$60 billion more more to zalinski that
they'll sell the rest of us out with a
fake border deal president Trump has
already smartly come out against any
bills struck with Biden which is sending
the Nikki Haley wing of the party into a
tizzy think about this Biden's Homeland
Security Department is again literally
suing Texas to prevent it from enforcing
the border and yet McConnell Lanford and
their other yes men like Kevin Kramer of
North Dakota Todd young of Indiana they
want you to believe that suddenly Biden
can be trusted to enforce new Provisions
what's interesting to me is there are a
lot of angry people out there and that's
why the Border crisis is the number one
issue for PE for voters I don't see how
we have a better story to tell when we
miss the one opportunity we have to fix
it anything that interrupts that
negotiation uh I think would be tragic I
don't doubt that he wants a perfect deal
so do I on it but we've got to be able
to figure out how to be able to do
something right now to get as much done
as we can Poss possibly get done now
with Republicans like these who the heck
needs
Democrats they all know that Biden
doesn't need legislation to fix the
Border plus one source with knowledge of
the text of the so-called bipartisan
border Bill tell us that it'll still
allow Biden to Parole in close to two
million migrants over his last year in
office and by the way in addition to
that FasTrack hundreds of thousands of
more foreign workers which is why
liberal open borders Democrats like
Chris Murphy are also anxious to Ram it
all through I hope we don't live in a
world today in which one person inside
the Republican Party holds so much power
that they could stop a bipartisan
Bill actually the one person who
actually had our border under control is
precisely the person we should be
listening to along with the American
people of course so Mitch McConnell
should now put an end to this nonsense
do it tonight CU all the exit polls even
in moderate New Hampshire show that
Americans believe that migrants are
hurting the country and they want this
flow stopped they don't want it managed
it will only be stopped though of course
when Trump's back in office so don't
pretend otherwise oh and by the way most
Americans aren't in favor of sending
more money to Ukraine either they want
to take care of business at home so do
your job
Senators Americans are smarter than
Washington thinks and I I I'm always
stunned at how little Washington thinks
of the common sense of the American
people they see that the uni party
didn't care much about securing our
border until they needed to find a way
to funnel more money to secure Ukraine's
border and they see that the Democrats
didn't care about it until the issue
started really hurting
Biden and The Telltale sign that the
angle has been right all along about the
Schumer Langford border sneak well
thirston Howell III is for it former
president Trump has indicated to
Senators that uh he does not want us to
solve the problem at the border uh he
wants to lay the blame for the border at
Biden uh and the idea that that someone
running for president would say please
hurt the country so I can blame my
opponent and help my politics is a uh a
shocking uh development
with such trenchant
analysis he still lost in 2012 that's
shocking now the whole notion that
Donald Trump or Republicans want chaos
at the border to use as an issue against
Biden is of course both fatuous and
untrue when Trump was President he ended
the chaos at the border even though it
made it easier for Biden to downplay the
importance of Border enforcement in the
2020 campaign from beginning to end
Trump and populace have been clear that
they want strong and effective border
enforcement no matter who's President
what's actually happening of course is
that Biden's team was working with Chuck
Schumer behind closed doors on a secret
deal that would not end the chaos at the
border it would have enshrined it and it
would have given the Biden
Administration not one but two political
victories first the stories in the media
about how the Republicans had agreed
with Biden on stronger enforcement
measures ridiculous and second that the
administration would still be free to do
Catch and Release which is again great
for the cartels and great for the human
traffickers literally nothing in the
country would improve except Biden's
political
fortunes it it would be suicidal for the
GOP to help Biden sweep the Border chaos
under the rug so that we can have even
more chaos once Biden is
reelected this issue should be presented
clearly to the voters in November it's a
clear choice it shouldn't be muddled
with a lot of talk about a deal that
would leave Biden's most destructive
policies
intact if the Biden Administration
really wants to take the Border issue
off the table in November they have the
legal authority to do it right now
tonight but they will not instead they
they'll do things like Sue Texas which
is actually daring the feds to remove
its border area razor wire
now last night I told Senator Ted Cruz
that someone should make come and take
it you know the Alamo style you know
deal the flag and put it on t-shirts
bumper stickers you know kind of new
gear for the occasion so he tweeted this
out today I love it to govern is to
choose and the Democrats choose open
borders they'd rather increase Trump's
chances of winning in November even than
doing what it takes right now which they
could do to serious enforce our
immigration laws and why are they doing
this because that's what Fanatics do and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else